it was a desperate attempt to stop this
couple being swept away
strangers slipped into a street in
central Aden fighting to pull them free
of the current it is rainy season in
Yemen but with neglected infrastructure
the water makes its own path through the
city turning roads into rivers many were
caught out and had to be saved from
their vehicles these boys trying to
cheer up a woman they rescued by singing
to her compounding the trauma is that
this also happened a month ago then the
UN had to bulldoze thousands of tons of
rubble and mud off the streets almost
5000 families were displaced the water
also harbors an invisible danger Yemen
is battling a cholera outbreak a disease
spread through water
some 400 kilometres north in the capital
sana residents are salvaging what they
can from floods a week ago heavy winds
and rain killed seven people injured
dozens damaged 16 refugee camps in the
neighboring government of marine soon
the heavy rain destroyed everything we
weren't expecting it and it came from
the mountains and swept everything away
without warning the rain took our
clothes buses everything in its path and
yet there is a potentially more ominous
disaster on the horizon Yemen has had
just one case of coronavirus the UN has
warned it will be catastrophic if it
catches hold here only half of Yemen's
medical facilities are functional the
population is acutely malnourished in
about eighty percent or twenty four
million people need aid to survive
multinational companies including
tetrapack and Unilever are donating tens
of thousands of virus testing kits to
Yemen the first shipment will arrive
next week a devastated health system and
neglected infrastructure are symptoms of
Yemen's five-year civil war whether it
will continue is under negotiation we've
all noted the continued violence what
mr. Griffis is doing is trying to get
the parties to agree to a nationwide
ceasefire sustainable nationwide
ceasefire those discussions are ongoing
obviously in challenging circumstances
but that's that's what he's trying to do
challenging circumstances for all that
the Yemenis a resolution can't come soon
enough
Charlotte Bellis aljazeera